high on life is an upcoming first person
shooter game made by Justin Roiland the
co-creator of Rick and Morty from what
we've seen in trailers the game features
an alien sci-fi world with talking guns
and a similar style of humor to other
Royal en projects like Rick and Morty
solar opposites and trovers saves the
universe so with all of that said here
is everything you need to know about
high on life
[Music]
high on life is being developed by
Squatch games squash games formerly
known as squash tendo was co-founded by
Justin Roiland and Tanya Watson who had
previously been an executive producer at
Riot games prior to high on life Squatch
games had a specific focus on creating
games for VR with their first game
accounting releasing in 2016. in 2019
they released a far bigger game with
Trover saves the universe that received
a mix to fairly positive reviews and
currently sits at 76 on Metacritic for
the PS4 version high life is squash
game's latest project with Justin
Roiland himself taking a major role in
the development of the game rather than
just being a namesake according to the
squanch games fa2 Rylan created the
original concept and has taken part in
the design and development while prior
games released by the studio had a heavy
focus on VR high on life was created for
good old 2D and will be a purely single
player experience with no multiplayer
also of note while the humor and visuals
are similar to Ricky and Morty as Justin
Roiland is highly involved they are
completely different universes and
totally unrelated selling humans is
strong you're the only one that can stop
them
[Music]
to take out the entire alien drug cartel
live sees you taking control of a
character who has recently graduated
from high school and has absolutely no
dreams or Ambitions in life until earth
is invaded by an alien cartel who want
to get high high on human beings and
sell them as drugs your character also
stumbles upon a foul-mouthed talking gun
or gatlian named Kenny and is also
tasked with saving more galleons who
serve as your alternate weapons and can
help you take down your foes early on
Kenny gives the character the ability to
teleport their own house around space
which the player does seemingly
unbeknownst to their sister who happens
to get transported against her will
meanwhile legendary yet washed up in
homeless Bounty Hunter Gene sees what's
going on and tries to take advantage of
the situation by crashing on the couch
and in exchange setting up the Bounty
five thousand so the player can find new
bounties of course he makes the deal
sweeter for himself in that if the
player dies he gets to keep the house
all of this leads to your character
becoming an Intergalactic Bounty Hunter
and chasing down the entire alien drug
cartel to save Humanity
tethering but I can also deflect attacks
as high life sees your character
becoming a bounty hunter the gameplay
lies in you choosing between various
contracts and going off to well hunt
them there is a level of non-linearity
here as you don't have to follow a
specific order with these bounties and
can take them on in any order you like
additionally according to the developers
they've tried to incorporate Light
metrovania Elements into the game with
more parts of each area you Traverse
being revisitable and more accessible as
you gain more and more abilities as far
as the weapons go each gun has three
modes with one always affecting
traversal your gun will come with a
primary and secondary fire as well as an
ability fire which can be used for
combat but also have an effect on how
the player interacts with the level
itself in the case of Kenny the first
gun your character collects his primary
fire seems to be a standard mid-range
gun and his ability shot is his glob
shot while the globshot can be used in
combat it also knocks down specific
walls allowing the player to access and
Traverse more areas not a gun but
another weapon we know a lot about at
this point is knifey knifey is a crude
mouth knife who of course stabs he seems
to be regularly if not always placed in
the player's alternate hand once you
manage to find him like other weapons in
the game knife he doesn't only stab but
can be used for traversal by tethering
onto environments additionally he can be
used to deflect certain attacks there's
also Swayze who has a primary attack
that embeds explosive crystals into your
enemies and whose secondary attack
creates a time-slowing bubble meanwhile
Gus is voiced by JB Smoove of Curb Your
Enthusiasm Fame and his primary fire is
your standard shotgun fare there's also
a fourth yellow gun that I honestly
don't know too much about yet on top of
all this your character has the ability
to use melee finishers outside of combat
your player has the ability to upgrade
various weapons and skills this includes
purchasing upgrades such as Dodge unit
which allows characters to better Dodge
enemies with the dash other purchasable
upgrades include a forward slide and
both health and weapon upgrades muscle
implant for example is an implant that
strengthens Kenny's primary shot and
multi-glob mod is an augmentation that
multiplies the amounts of slime Kenny
can generate for his glob shots not only
is the game non-linear in allowing to
choose the order of the bounties you
tackle but there's also plenty of side
quests there's also large number of
commercials players can watch on the
game's various TVs with added humor I've
been I look at the dinner's cold I
prepared for us where were you I was
just doing smuffle guffins and B-movie
is the game licensed which players can
watch are dubbed over Mystery Science
Theater style and speaking of the humor
this is a notably major element of the
game the dialogue includes both written
and improvised lines with the player's
guns regularly offering commentary about
what's happening and poking fun at
gaming tropes to add to the game's
replayability the dialogue you'll hear
depends on the gun you have equipped so
you'll actually get different
interactions depending on your gun many
of the zones and characters were created
with this humor in mind including places
like little cutie town a cute tiny
village that you can obliterate Godzilla
style or mac and cheese Brothers
Construction with a bunch of tough Union
guys you have to decide how to deal with
so don't embarrass me you think you
could just walk up into a mac and cheese
Brothers construction site like you're
some sort of [ __ ]
Jews
if you enjoy Justin roiland's sense of
humor and shows like Rick and Morty or
solar opposites it seems like you're in
for a major treat with the writing and
high on life and if not it's likely the
writing and humor won't be for you
foreign
releases the Xbox One Xbox series X
slash S and PC on December 13 2022 with
the price of sixty dollars it'll also be
available on Xbox game pass on its
release date
so are you planning on picking up or
playing Ohio life and what weapon is
your favorite so far let us know in the
comments below and I'll see you next
time
here we come that was the hardest part
behind us this is basically done we
finished this we are fully out
oh okay what is this